what is the relationship between
probation and the sealing of god's people
in uh in that in ezekiel 9 verse 4 god tells
the angel girl to the midst of the city through
the midst of jerusalem and set the mark upon the
forces of the men that sigh and cry for all the
abominations that be done in the midst thereof now
the mystery of men in the midst of god's people
you see god's greatest wrath is porter against
those who know and did not act appropriately
because to whom much is given much is required one
of the greatest catastrophes in all the bible is
the destruction of jerusalem not the destruction
of babylon the destruction of jerusalem this the
suffering was intense why because they were the
ones to whom the articles were entrusted and they
did nothing with it they misrepresented
it and misrepresented god to the world
and so the the closer probation if i got the
question clearly so restate the question again
no problem fast uh it is what is the relationship
between probation and the sealing of god's right
receiving of god is to shield is to identify
those who will not be the targets of god's seven
last place who will not be who will be saved and
secured in god's kingdom they are sealed in their
forehead meaning the mind is made up it is not
a mark it is not some barcode that you scan with
your iphone it is nothing of the kind it is an
intellectual a mental decision that you will serve
god regardless of what now the mark of the beast
is also an intellectual choice of choice of the
mind to serve a man with institution and so the
sealing of god must occur before probation closes
that is the chronology because god seals his
people then when the ceiling is over that's when
christ comes down and so the ceiling first then
uh when that is finished probation closes and so
the angel was told in ezekiel nine verse four put
a mark then god tells the angels from five six and
seven go through the city and just destroy destroy
old and young babies beginner the elders the
priests destroyed now this is not secular babylon
this is jerusalem that god is talking about
you see because we are the light of the world so
when we mislead the world we pay a heavier price
than the world yet the world will be destroyed yes
but those who were assigned to enlighten the world
and did not do it will pay a terrible price and
so the angel says after sealing now go through
and destroy everyone who does not have the seal
then in revelation seven verse three verse one
after these things i saw four angels standing
on the four corners of the earth having before
holding back the four winds of the earth and then
the angel rises from the east having the seal of
the living god in verse two and he sets up he sets
the seal on the foreheads of god's people there
we have twelve thousand each of the twelve tribes
from verse five to verse eight of revelation seven
and so the ceiling precedes the clause information
when the ceiling is finished probation closes now
the judgment is heaven is connected to that
because as our cases are examined with us and
that takes up another program altogether several
hours those whose profession match their lifestyle
you know they've been fearful to god what
they've said you know jesus said this people draw
they worship me with their lips but their
hearts are far from me okay there are people
who say praise the lord praise the lord praise
the lord but their lives are something else
the judgment is to see whose life is consistent
with profession and practice and those who meet
that standard they are sealed with the seal of
god and they're the ones who are protected from
the civilized plagues those who don't match that
they're the ones who cut off the ceiling precedes
the closer formation and proceeds the falling
of the seven last place and the ceiling is going
on now it's going on now we do not know when it
will end but based on the condition of the world
it can't last much longer amen amen and one
of the things i would love to give a simple
understanding of the sealing process if you
look at this water bottle that i'm holding if i
lay to the side the water can fall out
what you can do is you can put the cap
is the truth inside of you into the last dimension
and so we are completely sealed and then we
will see the closing of the probation thank you
you